posez lui vos questions on vous trouve
l'info roger se demande pourquoi
certaines personnes âgées et plus cher
que d'autres pour conserver leur permis
de conduire au québec à partir de 75 ans
il faut passer des examens médicaux
régulièrement pour continuer de conduire
couverts par l'assurance maladie
roger remarquer que les prix varient
beaucoup d'un médecin alors bienvenue à
la société de l'assurance automobile
alain bonjour c'est françois sens je ne
sais pas si je vais sur la facture
[Musique]
qu'elle est privée autant merci au
revoir
finalement rien ne réglemente les
terrifient cet examen
le code de déontologie des médecins leur
éthique d'être abusif
c'est très large la fédération des
omnipraticiens suggère aux médecins de
demander pour 66 7 230 $ et de 50 à 125
dollars remplir le formulaire
comparer les tarifs vous avez un médecin
de famille il peut vous s'épargner
l'examen en servant de votre bilan santé
annuel
posez votre question on vous trouve
l'info passer le mot
[Musique]